der abbau von rohstoffen auf dem mond
hirngespinst oder realistischer plan
helium-3 ist der stoff der als
treibstoff für fusionsreaktoren hier auf
der erde fungieren könnte
das isotop soll von robotern auf dem
mond abgebaut und dann zur erde
transportiert werden neben einigen
privaten unternehmen will auch china
dieses sogenannte moon mining
verwirklichen wie sehen die pläne
konkret aus und wer realistisch ist das
vorhaben wirklich klicks um science
fiction die gibt's jeden tag spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er kein video herzlich
willkommen vielhaber whatsapp abonniert
da kriegt er auf jeden fall noch 100
prozentiger die nachricht auf dem video
online geht ihr habt euch dieses thema
dort gewünscht jetzt chinas pläne im
weltall sind groß und alles läuft auf
eine permanente mondstation hinaus eines
der größten ziele dabei ist die suche
nach bodenschätzen vor allem helium 3
es besteht aus einem neutronen und zwei
protonen und ist ein gigantischer
energieträger mit einer tonne des
isotops könnte eine sieben millionen
stadt wohl ein jahr lang mit strom
versorgt werden
der wert von helium-3 ist also immens
der aufwand für den abbau auf dem mond
könnte sich tatsächlich rechnen helium-3
kommt auf der erde kaum vor
denn es stammt aus dem sonnenwind der
den mond aufgrund seines fehlenden
magnetfeldes gut erreicht und so kann
sich das helium 3 dort anlagern
das isotop eignet sich hervorragend als
brennstoff für die kernfusion bei der
fusion mit dem wasserstoff isotop
deuterium beispielsweise entstünde als
endprodukt helium 4
der große vorteil ist entsteht keine
radioaktive strahlung einen kleinen
nachteil gibt es aber auch zumindest
derzeit denn bislang sind noch keine
reaktoren entwickelt worden in denen das
helium 3 verbrannt werden könnte keiner
der reaktoren hat eine positive
energiebilanz bisher denn das große
problem es braucht sehr hohen druck und
temperaturen um zwei positiv geladene
atomkerne zu verschmelzen und das ist
mit heutiger technik noch nicht möglich
doch auch eine andere eigenschaft von
helium-3 könnte von großer bedeutung
sein denn es eignet sich tragischerweise
auch für den bombenbau und seine
sprengkraft ist gigantisch zudem wäre
auch eine weitere anwendung spannend und
zwar in der raumfahrt selbst raumschiffe
könnten mit einem fusions triebwerk mit
helium und helium 3
sehr viel schneller unterwegs sein statt
vier jahre hin und zurück würde eine
reise zum mars nur noch etwa drei monate
dauern aber auch für kühlmittel und
messinstrumente wird helium 3 benötigt
und so gibt es einige unternehmen die
sich mit dem sogenannten moon mining
also dem abbau von rohstoffen auf dem
mond beschäftigen dem medium drei sind
es übrigens auch noch andere wertvolle
rohstoffe die uns auf den mond locken
beispielsweise iridium und andere
seltene metalle die sich durch
meteoriteneinschläge dort angereichert
haben neben privaten unternehmen ist
aber vor allem china stark an der mond
erkundung interessiert anfang des jahres
gelang der große coup als erstes land
setzen die volksrepublik die raumsonde
kefir auf der rückseite des mondes ab
eine völlig unerforscht region
das war wirklich eine premiere und ein
neues kapitel in der luna erforschung so
die chinesische weltraumbehörde cns aber
auch symbolisch hatte was einen großen
wert denn die chinesen demonstrieren so
dass sie längst auf augenhöhe mit
westlichen ländern sind der chinesische
rover soll vor allem im so genannten
mare imperium also dem regen mehr des
mondes bodenproben nehmen die region
stellt das zweitgrößte mare des bundes
da von der fläche her ist es doppelt so
groß wie deutschland wirklich easy wäre
der helium 3 allerdings nicht der mond
boden muss dafür auf rund 700 grad
aufgeheizt werden erst so lässt sich das
glas aus dem reguliert also dem
mondstaub chinas vorstellungen zufolge
könnten roboter den abbau übernehmen ein
rover mit einem parabolspiegel auf dem
dach könnte das sonnenlicht einfangen
nach berechnungen eines amerikanischen
wissenschaftlers müssten bis zu 100
millionen tonnen reguliert umgegraben
werden um eine tonne helium 3 zu
gewinnen
40 tonnen helium bräuchte es dann um die
usa ein jahr lang mit strom zu versorgen
nicht wirklich effektiv also wenn man
ehrlich ist der transport zur erde
dagegen würden sie sich gar nicht mal so
problematisch gestalten da die
anziehungskraft des mondes nur etwa ein
siebtel der erdanziehungskraft besitzt
und einer rakete somit nur etwa ein
siebtel der schubkraft künftig
alternativ könnten hier auch weltraum
aufzüge ins spiel kommen wie manche
experten teams sagen denn ein seil für
einen solchen aufzug auf dem mond wüsste
viel kürzer sein als sie auf der erde
und auch die erdanziehungskraft
ist natürlich dort nicht vorhanden
sondern die mond anziehungskraft und die
ist viel schwächer und am gondeln könnte
dann das material in den weltraum
transportiert werden wir hatten hier ja
ausführlich becking substanzen fiction
oder berichtet theoretisch sei solch ein
aufzug möglich doch es fehle noch ein
technikum so ein langes seil zu fertigen
und zudem steht auch noch die
finanzierungsfrage im raum das sind also
alles fragen die noch offen sind doch
fest steht dass die chinesen ihre mond
erkundung wirklich ernst nehmen diese
derzeitige mission ist aber nämlich nur
ein kleiner zwischenschritt der großen
chinesischen vision im kommenden jahr
sollen chang e 5 und shanghai 62 kilo
monika stein zur erde bringen
seit mehr als 40 jahren würde dann
wieder material form und in irdischen
labors analysiert werden mondgestein
hatten bisher nur die astronauten von
drei städtischen roboter sondern und der
sechs apollo landung mit zur erde
bringen können die analysen sollen dann
zeigen ob sich die im mondboden
enthaltenen rohstoffe für eine
besiedlung eignen spätestens 2025 soll
dann eine mondbasis errichtet werden
dazu ein mitglied der chinesischen
akademie für raumfahrttechnologie es
wird zuerst ein unbemannter mond
stützpunkt sein den wir durch roboter
und künstliche intelligenz betreiben
werden in zukunft aber sollen dann auch
menschen auf dem mond leben können wie
kolonie auf dem mond unbedingt auf
dieses video von raum zeit lockt der
zukunft klicken hier werden die fragen
beantwortet wie realistisch ist der plan
und wie sinnvoll also draufklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran